- Whoo! This is my jam, ya'll!
- Your Phone Sober vs. Drunk
- Tinder
- Nope.
Nope.
Ehhh
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Oh my god! You're beautiful. Yes!
- Waze
- Where's the H&M?
- It says three minutes and watch out
because there's a police
officer spotted ahead.
- Oh. Good.
You are going to be
designated driver next time.
- I will! Next time I will!
- Ahh! How much farther
is this in and out?
We've been driving for
like twenty minutes.
- It's four hours and 38 minutes away.
- What!
- We're going to the one in Vegas!
- Flashlight
- Keys! Where are you?
(sighs) Where in the world are they?
Excuse me, have you seen my keys?
Have you seen my keys!
Where are they?
- Snapchat
(camera clicks) Thinkin of U!
(camera clicks) U Up?
- Uber
- I'm going to get us an Uber.
- You know, maybe we should just walk?
- Really?
- It's so nice out. Is that crazy?
- It'd be crazy not to.
- Let's do it.
- Alright. I'm going to get us an Uber.
- Naw! I can walk! I could even walk home.
- No! Fuck that!
Oh shit! It's five times surge pricing.
(man chuckles)
- Is that crazy?
- Let's be crazy.
- I feel crazy!
- I'm cra--
- Are you okay?
- I'm okay.
- Use your phone responsibly.
- Please match! Please
match! Please match!
Yes! Oh, come on!
Yes! Yes!
Oh, if we had met, I would
show you such a good time.
I would open the door for you and
buy you all the oysters you want.